- M: Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Mario Kart...with Ethan. E: Hey
E: How's it going? M: You didn't plug my channel in your video at all
*Laughter* E: No! M: How dare you!
E: Dude, you need it to. M: I do! We're back with more, we're gonna play Battle. We did one over on his channel
It went... *More Laughter*
E: It's Ethan from GameCreampies
*Mark laughs*
M: *Immitating Jack* WAPOOSH! Top of the mournin' to ya' Cunts!
M: *something about drybones* E: I thought you were gonna be Furry Peach!
*Both laughing*
M: Alright, well yeah, I got to do that now. E: Yep. Oh, I hated that- the "Ha!"
NO
M: I've no idea how furry Peach is....
*Ethan laughs at Mark*
E: Probably very cozy M: *Moan* Like a dream E: Mmm she's so soft.
M: *chuckle* SO plush. E: Like a down pillow M: *laughs* E: *Moans*
M: Let's do Wuhu Town
E: Wuhu Town! M: Wuhu Town
E: Wuuuhuuu
E: You go right over the crisp (?), and then you- and then you go down, and then that your stomach comes up to your throat
And It makes that noise, "Wuhu"
M: *laughs with confusion* What is-
Pressing on your lungs- E: Ahhh! -like Bender in Futurama, when he turned human then died. He was like WoOoOoOo!
E: I've never seen Futurama *Mark's mind explodes* M: WHAT!
E: I'M SORRY! M: WE just watched Hot Fuzz last night.
How much more do you have to watch before I accept you? E: *chuckles* So- So much more
apparently. M: Futurama isn't like as much as a necessity
I I imagine. Like there's- there's there certain shows and everything that are absolute must.
Like, Hot fuzz is a must, you have to see that. (yaaaaas)
E: Yeah, it's sooo goOd. M: oh my God!
*Both laugh*
M: Sorry.
E: got a little excited over Hot Fuzz
M: *laughing* close call!
Just Edgar Wright I thought about him and Baby Driver
M: aAAAAaAA
E: CREAM
M: *laughing*
Like mix it with your O face your "uh" and it's
CREAM
E: cream
*both laughing*
Let's do it for mine which is "HAAAA"
E:*Giggling*
M:CREAAM!
*Both adorably giggling*
M:ugh these are all canan now everyone write that in my wikipediaahahaha
Just like an added note, y'know like intresting FAQ
or like..like
It's just like
How does he..
*laughs* what is his O face
just... CREAAM!
E: CrEAM!
*Both laugh*
M: Ohhh it's so stupid E: Oh Edgar..
E: Make the girls go wild M: Edgar?
Oh Edgar Wright *both laugh*
M: I thought some *laughs*
M: I thought of Ed Edgar from Ed Edgar adoptallot * Both laughing their heads off*
M: Ed Edgar makes the girls go wild? E: *Still laughing*
E: Makes the girls go " CrEaM"
M: *Laughs*
M: Aaah Jeez
M: We're off to a bad start *laughs*
E: oh no..
E: Every video is a bad start
M: Pretty much..Oww
E: Y'know every video is a chance to make a difference
E: In someones life M: *starts laughing*
E: *also laughs*
E: And i think that that's.. whAt we're doing heRE today
M: People are gonna bring this video up when they meet us in person *laughs*
E: I hope so M: "I really needed to see a video of you today" *Both laugh*
M: "When  i open YouTube and you just.. 'CREAM'
*Both laugh* E: "I really needed that"
M: I.. *laughing*
E: You know people always say,
You don't always know what you want
You have to be show what you want
*Laughing their heads off again*
M: Not that we're shit talking anybody that does that- E: Yeah M: Like.. *laughs*
M: Cause you know every video is someones favourite video E: Yeah!
M: Right? Every video!
E: Weird
M: Even 'Fast.exe' have you ever seen..?
E: Yeah
E: Yeah, yeah M: You have?!?
E: Yeah! M: Really?
E: seen that
Old Mark: GOTTA GO FAST
M: I was li- I literally made that video to be like:
'How embarrassing can i make a video and people still defend me *laughs*
E: Mhm * Laughs too*
E: Have you- M: That really was my mindset behind it!
E: Have you seen my peen video?
M: Yeah! You sh- I love peen!!
E: Yeah!!
M: Peens great! E: People j- People have been telling me to delete peen!
M: WHAt?!
M: This is a live reaction to peen
E: Just in the middle of the Mario Kart video it'll turn into a reaction video
*both laugh* E: Moist man tits..
E: *laughs* The child
M: *Laughing his ass off* E: It took me like, 8 hours to edit M: That's how i made meow! E: *laughs*
M: That was literally how i made meow, i was like:
'Man i have no idea what i'm gonna do for my 10 million subscriber milestone'
M: It better be something epic-" E: Was that your ten million video? M: Yeah, yeah it was
E: Woah! M: I didn't even own up to it at first *laughs*
M: I was just like *Shy kinda voice* "I'll come with something tomorrow!"
M: It was the pressure of like, "i have to come up with something great" E: "Yeah"
M: "I'm gonna bide time while making something stupid in the meantime"
M: And it's like those stupid things that make the.. E: I need to to that again!
E: Because i haven't made a stupid video like that in a really really long time.
M: I LOVE making stupid videos!! E: And there so funny!
M: Anyway.. E: They're so good.. M: Links are in the description for these videos if you wanna see them
M: One more! E: Alright
M: Dragon Pa- no we already did dra- sweet king!
E: *laughs* Sweet king? *both laugh*
E: My sweet sweet king!
M: My king!
E: My creamy king! M: Ohh man
M: You know a video i don't know why it did so well was 'Sort the Cort'
E: Yeah! M: I had no idea why that video did so well!
E: Wait, how many views was that?
E: Was it like, astonishing? M: It got like, Multi million
E: Weird.. M: Like the first video got like three or four and the second got like similar
M: I have no idea..
M: *stutters*  did crazy well and i really didn't know why
M: And i was trying to like, dissect it i was..
I was playing the game on my own, like whyyy? Why is it so popular to people?
And like, maybe you guys in the comments can explain, like that video
Just went craaaazy good
It wasn't even a compelling thumbnail,
It was like just a piece of the game
Like and, and the story was interesting but the gameplay was slow
E: yeah.. M: And i was like whaat E: It's weird when like videos do really well that you don't expect to do well like,
A video on my channel it's..
'Mario Kart with Mark'
And it did really well and i don't know why * Both die laughing *
M: I was like really listening! I was like " Oh you got something to say in the conversation?"
E: No but uhh you played this recently.. uh the worlds EASY-est game?
M: Yeah E: That video did really well on my channel!
M:Yeah! E: I don't know why!
M: What's even weirder is it does well but the like ratio, the like numbers are similar to every other .. E: Yeah.
M: This is what YouTubers think about. like we think about what the numbers mean and there's no answer
Like MatPat may seem like he know's what he's talking about but half the time it's all guess work
Cause we don't have any like com- communication with YouTube
So everything's a mystery! E: Literally-
E: Literally none!  No communication. i got my, my uuh 100 thousand subscriber plaque stolen! M: Yeah!
E: And i c-can't get it back! M: Yeah!!
E: They just like.. i can't get in contact with YouTube for them to send me a new one! *both laugh*
E: It's so.. M: It's so sad too because obviously.. even I, I can't get that done!
E: Yeah! M: Like, i am one of the biggest channels on YouTube, i can't just go like " Hey get him his, get him his plaque
E: Yeah, Yeah M: I can't do that!!
E: It's just aaaaa it's ridiculous. M: Yeah
E: It's ridONCulous
M: Ridoncalous.. E: That uhh.. that video uhm..
because we were talking about like how,
The video does well on views but the likes are pretty normal
M: Yeah E: That video 'fun day in the sand'
Which is me digging in the sand saying uhh *sings* digging myself a grave!
M: * quietly sings* digging my self a grave.. E: That, that video.
That video has 100... just over 100k
But it has 20 thousand likes
M: Yeah! E: Which is like, REALLY good for a video with 100k M: Yeah!
E: Really good M: I mean it's just like the, the
The, there are so many videos out there that it's like
"What like-" I've asked myself this
What makes a good video?
Like nothing really makes it
Because the appeal of YouTube
And i think.. people's mistake is that
The, the, the videos that just seem like, genuine things,
Are the videos that will always do better
E: Yeah! M: Just because it feels more like:
Just "Hey! my friend made this cool video!" E: Yea!
M:Yeah E: Yeaaaaaa
M: Yeah
And that's what i like, that's what i love about doing the stupid videos!
Cause that's what makes it important!
E: Yeah! M: That's what makes it special!
E: Leader cream!
*Laughs* wh-what are we doing? *Laughs again*
M: I don't know man! Battle Stad? E: Battle Stad, we haven't done that
M: I don't know where you go half the time *Laughs*
E: Okay *Both Laughs*
M: You just go on a journey on your own, E: I do!
M: And sometimes i follow and sometimes i (inaudible) and sometimes i'm just like *Makes a face and a weird sound*
How did you're brain make that connection?
E: How How How?
That's a really fun game that i like to play it's
Talk and don't think
E: *Laughs* it's a dangerous one M: Oh god yeah!
E: But it's fun!
M: Yeah.. E: It's funny you just start talking and you don't think about it.
Just let the words flow right on out!
M: Yup! E: Mhm!
E: Play it at home! play it with your grandmother! M: *Laughs*
M: I mean it's good, just because it's
It, it helps create like this flow
Cause you know they always say, it's fuckin bullshit, but it's just like
"YOU don't create, your MIND creates"
E: OhhH! M: "You just have to let the creativity flow through you!"
M: It's just like...fucking!.okay..*Stammers*
Copernicus *Both laugh*
F-Fucking nig
*still laughing*
*Still laughing*
M: You know what i mean though right?
E: Yep M: Ah fuck it, nevermind
M: I'm I'm not gonna talk E: No! Keep going! Keep going!
M: No i don't want to! E: I'm waiting
M: ALRIGHT
M: So.. *laughs*
M: You know, it's just like
You're all you so you is the..
You that *Laughs*
*Both laugh* M: Just let this die
E: Alright Copernicus!
*Both laugh*
E: 0oOh M: It's like, that's a Brian Regan joke
M: Slow down Copernicus!
Peach just did a flip and like r-lifted her tail..
l-like that and its like r-ff sh f.. why'r- why is Peach flashing her Butthole.. *Both Giggling*
E: I dunno man, don't shame her for that
*both laughing hysterically*
M: I'm sorry you're right, i'm wrong E: C'mon be more open minded.
M: Open your mind sh-like she opens her butthole for you.
E: Horrible... Horrible M: No that's not good
M: I'm on a roll though i'm opening my mind and i'm not thinking *Ethan laughing uncontrollably in the background*
E: Close it, Close it!, CLOSE IT! Before it's too late!
E: Before you accidentally say cunt!
E: If you've been following this series, accross both of our channels.
E: You'll find that may be entertaining M: You'll know
E: Ahh I got third M: WHOOOO!
M: I dunno why I did better that time.
M: I was not paying attention
E: You got like.. last place last time, didn't you?
M: Ooh ye, I got first every other time though!
M: So that's better.
M: Anyway so this has been fun! Thank you Ethan for joining me. E: Yeah, thanks!
M: Links in the description for Peen, Fast.exe, and his video that we did, but I know you're going to watch the other ones first.
M: So Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always. We'll see You in the next video!
Bye-Bye! E: Bye!